too early to celebrate
in an election too close to call
followers of radical left-wing candidate
pedro castillo dance
after an exit poll put him in the lead
of six front runners
peruvians voted on sunday under the
shadow of covet 19.
the brazilian variant is fast spreading
around the country
the pandemic has hit peru hard tens of
thousands of people have died
but for many peruvians an election
always brings some hope for change
i hope with my heart that the vote will
be meaningful because we're living in
very tough times i hope we elect someone
who understands the situation
and governs with his i heart
zero corruption better health care
education and jobs
the last presidential five-year term was
marred by political instability
as november violent protests put an end
to days of chaos
that left three presidents ousted and
sworn in in one week
analysts say a new election won't
guarantee political stability
there are 20 political parties running
for congress because the vote is so
fragmented
analysts say at least 10 parties will
win seats making governing very
difficult for
any new incumbent most peruvians are
disenchanted with the country's
political class
and that's why juan pedes says he only
votes because it's mandatory
too many things are wrong in this
country i'm going to turn 60 and nothing
has changed
they make promises and it sounds like
the same scratched record
i'm voting to avoid the fine peruvians
anxious with results
may still have to wait some time vote
counting is by hand
and with such fragmented results a run
of vote is expected
mariana sanchez lima peru